heads up for those that may still be
contemplating purchasing the fallout 4
season pass the price is going up from
thirty dollars all the way up to fifty
dollars on march first so if you want to
get it for cheaper price you'll have to
get it today as previously announced a
price increase is a result of Bethesda's
expanded DLC plan the studio has said it
will now deliver more than sixty dollars
worth of new fall our adventures and
features in 2016 first three fallout 4
expand choose our automaton wasteland
workshop and far harbor on top of these
paid expansions Bethesda has promised to
support fallout 4 with more free updates
anatomic trono carrots called the
mechanist releases a horde of evil
robots into post-apocalyptic boston one
of which is the devious Robo brain
players will have to track them down and
use their parts to build a robot of
their very own wasteland workshop
meanwhile lets players design and set
cages to capture live creatures from
Raiders to death claws and then tame
them or even have them face off in
battle Bar Harbor is the most expensive
of the three price of twenty-five
dollars in it you take on a mission from
the Valentine's detective agency to find
a young woman and a secret colony of
synths far Harbor features the largest
landmass for an ad on the Bethesda have
ever created filled with new faction
quests settlements lethal creatures and
dungeons in other fallout 4 News
Bethesda has announced official mod
support will be rolled out after the
first DLC is released in March with mod
tools hitting PC in April so do you
think the more fallout content would be
rad or are you all burnt out let us know
in the comment section below or you can
find me on Twitter at irregular Dave and
for all your gaming entertainment news
stay tuned to gamespot com
you